I just saw the most nauseating news
story I have ever seen in my entire life
and it came out yesterday and you paid
for it actually
no you didn't pay for it with your daily
wire subscription you paid for it with
your tax dollars because it was on NPR
and I'm going to urge
listener discretion right now and viewer
discretion if if you have a weak stomach
just skip forward one minute right now
just one minute that's all it's really
going to take
because NPR aired the audio of a woman's
abortion NPR aired
the the room with the doctors you know
with the abortionists and a mother
murdering her own child and
play the tape
she's from Michigan she already has one
kid she's having her abortion at about
11 weeks nearly all abortions in
Michigan are before 13 weeks put a pause
right there I just had well I didn't
just have my second child my wife had my
second child but you know it's a group
effort at least to some degree I
participated at least you know in the
very beginning and we would go to the
sonograms
11 weeks
not only do you know the sex of your
child not only are the basic features of
your child quite formed at that point 11
weeks that baby is a baby
that baby is moving around that baby is
recognizable as a baby 11 weeks is
is pretty far along
and so they're saying this this woman
who's already got one child out here in
the world
is going into this room
to murder her child who is 11 weeks who
is
you know that this baby is a baby
you know mothers and mothers know really
instantly but
and and you know that this mother knows
that this baby is a baby because the
mother is crying in the audio and it's
not tears of joy again if you've got a
weak stomach
just skip ahead one or two clicks right
now and you'll move past the Audio I
think it's important to hear it though
because I think that this news story
completely backfired on NPR
unlike many patients at Northland she
said I could record her procedure we're
going to hear some of that now so I am
just going to get you set up on the
table and we're going to do
coffee I'm gonna pull this out under
your legs most patients are partially
awake during the procedures they get IV
medication for pain and anxiety the
lights are dimmed they're soothing music
it actually feels a lot like a
childbirth the medical gown your bare
legs and stirrups and a person next to
you saying you can do this
breathing
that's Brandy she's one of the staffers
her job is to monitor vital signs but it
is also to hold the patient's hand and
talk her through this whether it's a
birth or an abortion it is often women
guiding other women you're going to hear
this machine turn on now okay makes a
loud noise
[Music]
blow it out if you hold your rabbit just
makes it harder for you keep breathing
keep just keep breathing Brandi tells
her over and over I can't the patient
says at one point when the cramps get
painful yes you can Brandi tells her
you're doing it
and then within just a couple of minutes
it's over
[Music]
take some deep breaths for me
[Music]
you did it hmm
thank you guys so much
[Music]
you're fine
I
really went back and forth over whether
to play that on the show or not because
it's truly nauseating and I bet that
I bet that many of you are sick to your
stomach hearing it
and it's not because you haven't it's
not because you haven't seen violence
before or heard violence or probably
seen or heard people die on video I mean
we see crime videos we've seen seen
videos from war
real video I'm not talking about
Hollywood or anything like that you've
seen news footage from Wars you've
you've seen crime videos you've probably
seen or heard people die before there's
something especially nauseating about
this even compared to crime videos or
war videos
because it's a mother doing it and the
way the way that this NPR host
introduces it she says
you know it's in many ways this
procedure is a lot like giving birth
yeah it is because you are giving birth
it's just instead of giving birth to a
living baby to nurture this baby and
care for this baby as you ought to do
you're giving birth to a baby that
you've
likely already killed in the womb and
then you're giving birth to it to throw
them away in the trash
so it's
it's just it's just nauseating
and
someone wrote in when this story was
going viral the reason I ended up
deciding that we should play it on the
air is because this was this was on
National Public Radio
this was
as
public as it could possibly be public in
the sense that yes it was aired in on a
mainstream platform but public in that
our political system paid for it you
paid for for this to to Air and I
believe the reason that NPR chose to do
it because NPR is very far left and why
we funded I have no idea but the reason
they chose to do it is because they
think that it's going to destigmatize
and demystify abortion well yes it will
demystify abortion because it will get
rid of the euphemisms that people always
use Reproductive Rights Women's Health
Care all these euphemisms that are
actually are deceptive that actually not
not only do they sugarcoat the procedure
but they they invert it they say it's
it's reproductive it's not it's the
opposite of reproductive they say it's
Healthcare it's not Healthcare it's
murder and and so it demystifies it but
I don't think it destigmatizes it I
think it it
really demonstrates to people why there
is a stigma around abortion there's a
stigma around abortion because it's the
murder of a child
and so I think it completely backfires
and I think it's actually important to
amplify this for for people to see
they're into here to hear the reality of
it
some mouthy lib that I saw on social
media when I posted this along with
other people
said oh you're so sickened by this what
you've never seen video of a school
shooting and I thought first of all no I
never have seen video of a school
shooting I don't I don't know that
anyone has are there videos of the
school shootings I don't think so but
furthermore even if such a thing existed
this would be worse
because
killing is a fact of life if this is a
fallen world and it's a sin that just
exists there is murder in the world and
there's war and there's just regular
Street murder and there's even there's
even murder in high schools and there's
even murder of poor little children and
all these things
but it's even worse when the murderer is
the mother it's so much more perverse I
mean this was Mother Teresa's speech to
the U.N she said the the biggest problem
in the world today the the cause of of
political evils more so than any other
cause
is abortion because if a mother can kill
her own child then there's nothing that
that anyone won't do
absolutely horrifying stuff all right
there's more to get to I've got the
regular old written mailbags I'm going
to get to a few of those in the member
block and then it is fake headline
Friday so I will need your help
Ben Davies has given me
four real headlines one fake headline
he's going to test my ability to
understand our always absurd news cycle
to parse fact from fiction the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]